i can't even imagine like the stress on
your family with all the the working but
the obvious question to me is
why do you do your own editing
listen man this is a trap that i don't i
can't even answer it you know what it is
i started filming the reason i bought a
camera was to edit i really enjoyed
editing so i think there's this weird
part of me that's like i can create it
the way i want i regret it every night
every night i'm sitting there the
family's going to bed and i'm like how
to knock this video out bro you're still
doing the editing i still edit
to steve quite a bit i mean like here's
the thing like i have an editor but i am
like the gnarliest like
over-the-shoulder nightmare for that
like i mean i'm in the i spend like
way too much time in the bay and like
but at least i got somebody to get it
into like decent shape i'm not like
putting it in there to begin with and
creating the timeline and sucking it up
and like yeah so i come in after the
fact the biggest step
the biggest new thing is i have somebody
chopping the podcast
at least to its final form and then i go
through and i just dude like with the
podcast you can't really and it's easier
to edit because it is a production
multicam it's it's it's it is what it is
right yeah with vlogging it's like did i
me do i look stupid an editor might not
catch it right i know if i look stupid
because i'm judging you don't look
stupid can you really hand somebody your
baby right and i have tried it and i've
done it uh many times
currently i'm just rocking it dude it's
insane
the work ethic is is insane i think that
clip was awesome but not as awesome as
my new book a hard kick in the nuts what
i've learned from a lifetime of terrible
decisions which is out september 27th
and if you pre-order it right now you
can get the autographed copy so
get on it man pre-order my book it's not
going to waste your time because i'm
proven dude new york times bestseller my
first book's five star rated on amazon
and i have no doubt this one will be two
so get the autographed copy right now by
pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude